an ela vlog good how are you I'm good
it's so great to see you a little bit
different these days now it's via zoom
instead of a person how are you doing
how's Quarantine life for you I'm doing
pretty good thank you I'm pretty bored
but we're finding things to do so yeah
yeah all right your family yeah so right
now I'm with my mom and Hailey and all
my god
oh how are you guys like how are you
passing the time having you're lucky
because you do have the family all
together like I'm all Los Angeles so
it's nice that you have people to you
know hang out with how are you guys
passing the time yeah I don't know what
I would do if I were all alone I think
I'm so bored
so at first I was super boring I don't
know to do like one with us to do if I
can't go out but I feel like we're
slowly kind of adapting to like this
being not our new normal or anything but
it's gotten to a point where just like
this is what we're doing now so we just
have to like deal with it so we've been
going at the pool we've been tanning
trying to get outside when we can when
the sun's out
I've learned that my family is not very
good at puzzles we've tried we've tried
like a thousand-piece puzzle so I don't
know why we were like but you know what
let's go for the big go big or go home
so you might like do that q I found
these puzzles and they literally did not
get a single piece I mean these days I
feel like to be honest are going by so
quickly because there are like you just
kind of get sidetracked during the day
from one thing another and then yeah I
feel like it's just kind of like a
repeat cycle like sleep do some work eat
a lot of the day is focused around
eating now what are you guys like what
is your guilty pleasure what are you
craving during quarantine honestly I did
not know that I love tacos as much as I
knew that they were like good or
whatever it's like I would definitely
but like I can do now we probably made
tacos like 10 times Taco Tuesday taco
every day yeah but I love tacos I think
we want to try to make this dessert but
we've never gotten around to it like
this lemon thing and definitely not
bakers so we'll see how about
let's see that could be something that
you take up especially as like a family
to learn together during quarantine I
mean what are what's something that
you've learned about yourself or maybe
picked up a new hobby or asset during
this time um okay so I'm not very good
at it but I do enjoy painting I did that
yesterday I'm going to get her but
that's definitely one I'm not showing it
another thing is that I like eating at
my house more than I thought I did
because normally like we ate a like even
house fast food like a restaurant
yes we've been eating at my house of
course every day it's not as bad as I
thought it was so I feel like after step
when we go back whenever that is
I'll be ready to like eat at home and I
think that's better for you number one
and just saw yeah yes a nice home-cooked
meal are you are you contributing to the
cooking or is it all the your family
it's mostly me and my mom okay good okay
oh it's probably more my mom but I do
help out a little bit yeah I would say
that's such a nice bonding experience
though for you and your mom especially I
mean how would you say this time being
at home has kind of strengthen your bond
with your entire face yeah because Haley
and I even though we do we're really
close we hang out all the time I'm
normally on static she's normally on set
and normally it's like same satellite
one person going up there one person's
going over here and I feel like for the
first while like quarantine we still
were kind of that way where I put my
room she'd go in her room oh we have
them like making up dances together and
doing what like siblings ooh and
yesterday we went outside and I
practicing gymnastics just because I
wanted to of us past at the time and she
was like teach me something so like I
was trying to jerk a back walkover so
yeah I think we've definitely become
closer it away you know I feel like we
were already close but we've been a lot
and watching movies and TV shows and all
of that but what are you guys watching
what are you binging on for me it's
Criminal Minds yeah
and welcome let's shoot I think is
binging and with Annie she's like on the
third season she spots from been
watching if like two days and like how
do you do that
but yeah and for movies we just have
been watching everything that's on that
flake sir really anything that we can
watch you're in quarantine you're binge
watching these shows and you're watching
these movies is it inspiring you to kind
of like add more things to your vision
board or oh I'm gonna do something like
this 100 and after I watched Criminal
Minds all my dreams have been about FBI
and I'm like no what
maybe I should like be the play role of
an FBI agent or like be an FBI agent
like I could do anything oh my gosh I
could see you in that little FBI uniform
on camera acting I mean I feel like that
would be the best of both I'm just
seeing my happy place to end really all
right let's do it oh my god give her the
Emmy now we can see it I love that what
about when it comes to music I know like
I feel you know it's it's different
because I've been talking to a lot of
people via zoom you know during this
this quarantine time and some people are
more inspired some people are kind of
taking a backseat letting them just kind
of relax for the first time in like ever
how is it for you when it comes to music
is this time creative for you or you
just kind of like taking a break I feel
like kind of both I feel like we we've
been trying to like this is a good time
to like start focusing on music and like
really sit down and like talk about what
we want and like get this thing done and
we have but it's also just something
kind of slow process just because I'm
not in a rush and normally like being in
non quarantine we're gonna like a
schedule that we have to get done so it
just goes by faster I guess like right
now like we're getting things done but
it just kind of feels like it's slower
than normal
what about when it comes to your YouTube
channel cuz I notice you know you've
been on the platform for literally over
a decade now making these videos and you
know you haven't posted in a few months
actually like almost a half of a year is
that something intentional where you
wanna you know take a step back to
refocus on what kind of content you're
pretty
now I actually cannot believe it's been
six months I mean I can it's insane but
it's felt really really great to not see
films all the time because even in
quarantine I feel like I've already been
getting so much a break in food we're
doing hit YouTube I'd be like having
cameras we were daily vlogging for five
yeah and we went to weekly because it
was just like we weren't do we didn't
have anything to film and the whole
reason why we started was just because
it was fun and is what we wanted to do
and we were just getting content and it
wasn't like a thing that we felt
obligated to do so when we came to LA
and all we were doing was being on set
just we never got anything we're just
like always stressful we're like okay we
have to have find something to film and
we were having to like go and look for
stuff which isn't a bad thing because it
was what we did but we decided to go to
weekly because of just everything that
was going on in our lives so it was just
better for everybody the fans were super
understanding which helped us so much
and then after a while we were just kind
of like this is working for us and we're
getting other things done were excited
about those other things and we've been
on YouTube for 10 years let it be good
to let go without that part of our lives
and start a new chapter and I think
we've done a pretty good job on that and
I feel a lot better and huh and just
more motivated to like actually work and
do things even when you said I feel
happy like you have a smile that's like
beaming from ear to ear you know I feel
like this YouTube channel has been such
a huge part of your life and your
childhood growing up and putting these
videos out there I mean where do you see
the future of your channel going will
you continue to post videos when it
feels right for you when it doesn't feel
like a not a burden but like I have to
do this video today um yeah I think
occasionally just because if it on
quarantine like I have my own channel
dysphoria that is what I was talking
about I didn't have my own channel but I
like these music videos on and like all
that stuff for sometimes I do want to
like sit down and film videos just
because it's fun like it's
what we do but yeah I think I think I
when the time feels right yeah I mean
it's not something that we're like no no
more videos we're not doing tube it's
just right now it's better if we do
other things
yeah well that's I feel like part music
to people's ears because I know a lot of
people love the behind-the-scenes
footage especially of you and Asher that
you guys bless our YouTube feeds with I
actually just talked to him a couple
weeks ago about his new music and he
misses you so much I know you guys
haven't been able to sir
during this quarantine I mean what do
you miss most about your boyfriend oh my
god everything I think is so sad like
guys pretty sure you had like a date
miss calendar like the last time we saw
each other I'm pretty sure it's like
almost 60 days which is insane and for
me and Asher it's normally pretty easy
to like be away from each other just
because though it's kind of like how our
relationship started was he was in
Arizona and I was in LA like first three
months we were just like face I think so
it came pretty naturally to us to like
go back to that and like reassure
everything like we're really good at
communicating in that way but it's just
like all my friends like half like their
boyfriends like all of their friends
like it's kind of hard to them like like
to boiling some people like allowed to
see their boyfriends and in brightly my
boyfriend is in another state right now
and yeah but my mom did say that after
this quarantine is done we might be able
to go and drive yay hey you know what
they say distance make art grow fonder
right I love it you know Annie at 15 you
have done so much and I'm so happy for
you
both personally and professionally I
mean what else do you have that you
still want to do alright I definitely
want to have a movie in the theaters I
think that's definitely one of my goals
but like with like a real like
everything like not just like you know
like a low-budget like typing rich like
Navy in the theater it's like I want to
like
real yes I'm not like I don't need to be
like a starring role I need to just I
just want to be able to like buy tickets
to my own movie and let's go to the
premiere in Milan movie I think that
would be incredible um going on a tour
even like like I said even if I'm not
headlining just just having that
experience I guess it's super cool so
yeah I mean there's a lot of things that
I want to do so you know what speak it
into existence girl and you know in no
time I guarantee you I'm gonna be
digging up this footage showing it to
you while we're on the red carpet for
your movie look you you you manifested
this you buddy [ __ ] whazzup
yeah you believed in yourself and I mean
I feel like that is something especially
at such a young age
you know you have to have that core
belief in yourself and in your dreams I
mean what kind of advice do you give to
your fans and other young artists who
want to follow in your footsteps
yeah um honestly I feel like I say this
all the time and it's kind of like
cliche I guess but like just it sounds
so like of course you're gonna say
that's like be yourself because that's
what people are gonna really like at the
end of the day just you being you and
you being something that they can really
do even but you don't have to like be
relatable I'd just be yourself and they
will someone it's gonna be like oh I
agree with that and I feel like just
being you and being happy being honest
is just something that you always have
to yeah
[Music]